pierre marie est la quatrième génération
d'éleveurs son exploitation qui a
toujours mis un point d'honneur à être
présente dans les conflits à la tête de
80 maire de la race to phone ici le
travail de sélection de la race produit
des champions ici va nous ne
représenterons l'élevage à la porte de
versailles
ça nous permet de comparer nos animaux
avec les autres il faut qu'on améliore
c'est quand même des délégations qui
viennent et puis qui par la suite
peuvent acheter des animaux
l'art est folle outre le suffolk le fils
et le père ont aussi un troupeau
inscrits de charlez mais en raison de la
conjoncture économique toujours plus
tendu pour les producteurs de viande
bovine
ils ont renoncé à les emmener jusqu au
concours général de paris
on a plus de frais et que certains parce
que bon on a les contrôles de croissance
on allait le marquage
aloès nous avons d'autres les pointages
tout ça tout ça engage des frais des
cotisations supplémentaires
donc il faudrait qu'on soit un petit peu
connu mais reid de ça de notre produit
si actuellement la viande ovine se porte
un peu mieux que le boeuf
il n'empêche que pierre marie est très
touché par la situation de ses confrères
confronté aux turbulences qui agitent le
monde agricole
la redéfinition des zones défavorisées
en étant le dernier exemple je vois pas
ce qu'ils attendent de nous faire nos
chers élus et puis voilà que s'ils
veulent qu'on disparaisse mais il mettra
la clé sous la porte et puis voilà sans
parler des suicides qu'il y a on entend
parler tout le temps quoi donc c'est
voilà je ne sais pas ce qu'ils attendent
mais je voudrais bien voir une réponse
par contre pourtant chez les bas vous l
amour des bêtes et du travail bien fait
ne faiblit pas et la relève est peut
être déjà là antoine le fils de pierre
marie du haut de son jeune âge adore
paraît-il cette atmosphère de concours
et les sucres folkeux de la ferme
la passion n'a pas d'âge